in deutschland am donnerstag herzlich
willkommen zu unserem corona kompakt die
immer mit den neuesten entwicklungen im
überblick unter anderem was bedeutet der
neue schnelltest für die aktuelle lage
das besprechen wir gleich mit dem
biologen professor hendrik streik auch
neu auf dem markt sind abstands westen
die anzeigen wie weit man sich entfernen
soll ist das einer der schlüssel zur
eindämmung der pandemie ein corona virus
schnelltest der technologiekonzern bosch
verspricht das ergebnis soll bereits
zweieinhalb stunden nach der probe
abgabe vorliegen der test ist ein test
für den crooner virus auf das erbgut des
corona virus man muss im prinzip nur die
probe aus einem rachenabstrich unter dem
nasenabstrich eingeben und in der
kartusche in der in dem gerät erfolgt
dann die analyse vollautomatisch und
nach zweieinhalb stunden bekommt dann
der arzt beziehungsweise das labor das
ergebnis mit 95 prozent garantiert der
hersteller eine hohe zuverlässigkeit die
frage wie oft das system fehler macht
ist allerdings noch offen
grund genug weitere tests abzuwarten das
ist also sicherlich nicht das was uns
hier an dem punkt jetzt hilft das ist
ein test der auch andere erkältungsviren
abgreift ich glaube dass wir mit den
labortest deutlich höheren durchsatz
gewährleisten können aber eine
ergänzende maßnahme mag es durchaus sein
ab april soll der schnelltests direkt in
arztpraxen oder krankenhäusern gemacht
werden können
die sicherste methode sich corona vom
hals zu halten ist nach wie vor neben
dem obligatorischen händewaschen vor
allem abstand daran denkt nicht immer
jeder
gerade unter stress vergessen die
menschen die so wichtige distanz wir
selber waren einkaufen und satz gestört
dass die leute so nah an uns ran
gekommen
und dann kamen wir können auch
warnwesten bedrohung gibt corona keine
chance abstand halten so der simple wie
eindringliche slogan der vor allem im
alltag daran erinnern soll wie man eine
infektion mit dem virus am
effizientesten ausschließt
eine stille mahnende erinnerung für alle
wer braucht gerade an die leute gedacht
die nicht so gerne reden oder die nicht
jedem sagen wollen geh doch mal ein
stück weg weil gerade diese
risikogruppen die auch alleine wohnen wo
die kinder vielleicht 100 kilometer von
weg weit weg wurden die dann keinen
haben der für sie einkaufen geht die öh
sei trotzdem raus und die nachfrage ist
groß
also ich denke das ist im moment auf
jeden fall sinnvoll da einige menschen
das immer noch nicht verstanden haben
dass abstand jetzt gerade wichtiger ist
als nena ich habe mir diese weise
bestellt weil ich das gut was das solle
jetzt darauf geachtet wird den abstand
zu halten denn manches mal vergisst man
es doch ein bisschen und insofern finde
ich das richtig okay für die klasse 40
1558 infizierte und 229 tote so der
aktuelle stand
doch die zahlen werden steigen der
professor hendrix trick ist der direktor
des instituts für virologie am
universitätsklinikum bonn und uns jetzt
zugeschaltet herr professor was glauben
sie kann der schnelltest an der
aktuellen lage etwas verändern
wir kennen ja diese schnelltests auch
aus anderen viralen bereichen schon dass
es jetzt eben eine schöne entwicklung
die sich darauf markt wieder etabliert
das sieht ungefähr so aus so ein
schnelltest der soeben aber das problem
ist dass man nur einen einzelnen
menschen damit testen kann
im vergleich dazu das geht natürlich
sehr schnell im vergleich dazu machen
wir auf solchen platten gleich 80 90
patienten gleichzeitig jede sind so eine
einzelnen einbuchtung so dass wir hier
sehr viel mehr menschen gleichzeitig
testen können
in notfällen sind solche kartuschen
systeme natürlich extrem sinnvoll dass
sowas benutzt wird aber um die deutschen
durch zu testen und wirklich viel zu
testen in der breite zu gehen sind
solche herkömmlichen test einfach sehr
viel zweck bringen dabei dir einfach
eine größere masse gleichzeitig testen
sowas wird nach einem patienten dann
natürlich weggeworfen
danke für den professor strick und
gleich beantworten sie ja noch weitere
zuschauer fragen was für eine fiese neue
masche betrüger nutzen die aktuelle
krise aus um geld abzuzocken der
enkeltrick wird gerade zum beispiel
ausgebaut
anrufer täuschen vor angehörige mit
corona infektionen zu sein
corona hat die welt verändert die
straßen sind leer
geschäfte und restaurants geschlossen
und viele menschen sind über tage allein
in ihren wohnungen isoliert ohne
ansprache
wir haben in der vergangenheit auch
schon immer wieder feststellen können
dass krisenzeiten auch neue formen von
kriminalität mit sich bringen
dh wenn man es positiv formulieren
wollen würde die kreativität von
kriminellen stellt sich natürlich sehr
schnell ein auf neue gegebenheiten auf
neue umstände und das sehen wir auch
hier die korona krise führt dazu dass
menschen sich in angst befinden sorge
haben um ihre angehörigen und das wird
von einzelnen kriminellen sofort
ausgenutzt
es war eine dreiste tricks beschäftigen
die polizei zurzeit besonders der erste
eine variante des bekannten enkeltricks
ein älteres opfer ein unbekannter
anrufer und dann ein perfides spiel mit
angst und liebe
in dem in einem telefonat vor gespielt
wird das sehr nahe angehöriger in einer
notsituation ist er ist also infiziert
und bräuchte jetzt medikamente die
relativ teuer sind und man bittet um
bargeld
trotz aller sorge um den vermeintlich
bedürftigen enkel oder die gefährdete
nicht jetzt heißt es kühlen kopf
bewahren
zunächst mal wichtig zu wissen dass die
meisten dieser betrüger auf einer
rhetorischen ebene also in der direkten
form der ansprache relativ gut
ausgebildet sind das heißt sie finden in
den ersten worten und sätzen eine
möglichkeit kontakt anzubahnen aber dann
kommt der entscheidende punkt dann kann
man solche täter nämlich auch entdecken
oder entlarven weil sie dann relativ
schnell darauf bezug nehmen dass man
geld bezahlen soll das man irgendeine
tätigkeit ausführen sollen das heißt sie
versuchen eine drucksituation
herzustellen und dann unmittelbar daraus
kapital zu schlagen die erste reaktion
natürlich könnte sein dass man das
gespräch beendet noch wichtig ist
natürlich dass man kein geld
transferiert und kein geld in fremde
hände gibt nur also die um keinen
unbekannten schmuckgegenstände oder
bargeld übergeben
die erfahrung zeigt der enkeltrick
trifft häufig auch andere menschen in
unmittelbarer nachbarschaft deshalb
ebenso wichtig sofort die polizei
informieren
die täter arbeiten ja arbeitsteilig das
heißt es gibt eine einmal eine gruppe
die ruft an ständigen kontakt zum opfer
her
und dann gibt es nur zweiter profi teams
ist also ganz wichtig zu erfahren in
welcher region jetzt diese zweite
tätergruppe tätig ist können wir nämlich
davon ausgeht dass noch weitere opfer
gleich generiert werden und wir können
natürlich auch die banken warnen aber es
geht in diesen tagen nicht allein um
telefonbetrug die neuesten
polizeiberichte zeigen auch eine andere
alte masche gibt es jetzt in einer neuen
version
die täter können auch direkt an der
haustür klingeln und vorreden sie sagen
mitarbeiter punkt gesundheitsamt oder
von der polizei und sie verbrauchen
tests oder
führen tests durch und verlangen dafür
eine summe von ex euro in der regel ist
es so dass vor ort keine mitarbeitern
vom gesundheitsamt oder von der polizei
erscheinen und führen dort an der
haustür tests durch deshalb gilt
eintritt verweigern kontakt abbrechen
polizei informieren wer handelt kann
andere schützen er kann helfen weitere
straftaten zu verhindern
dieser austausch mit anderen führt dazu
dass ängste reduziert werden und dass
informationen weitergegeben werden die
das risiko reduzieren dass man opfer von
solchen betrugsmaschen wird corona
isoliert die menschen es muss sie aber
nicht zu opfern hinterhältiger betrüger
machen
ja und auch andere nutzen die aktuelle
situation aus nämlich raser die leeren
straßen laden manche zu hohem tempo ein
aber genau das ist natürlich nach wie
vor genauso verboten und genauso
gefährlich
der sprit ist billig die straßen leer
man könnte meinen corona hat nicht nur
schlechte seiten aber wie immer gibt es
leute die die situation ausnutzen
zum einen melden immer mehr tankstellen
versuche von hamsterkäufen
zum anderen betrachten einige autofahrer
die leeren straßen als rennstrecke doch
da gibt es ja noch die polizei und die
greift rigoros durch die straßen werden
leerer die verkehrsteilnehmer nutzen das
aus und da können wir natürlich dringend
als polizei nur appellieren halten sich
an die gültigen geschwindigkeitsregelung
und da appelle bei manchen nicht helfen
setzt die polizei verstärkt blitzer ein
mit erfolg
ein verkehrsteilnehmer auf der celler
straße und 28 jähriger mit seinem
mercedes bei gültigen 50 km h mit 124
erwischt worden
den jungen mann erwarten 680 euro
bußgeld und ein fahrverbot für drei
monate
noch bunter treibt es ein bmw fahrer auf
der autobahn 7 in richtung hamburg
bei erlaubten 100 kilometer pro stunde
können die verkehrspolizisten ihm eine
geschwindigkeit von 225 nachweisen
und als wenn das nicht reicht erwischen
sie den 35 jährigen mit dem handy
auch er muss tief in die tasche greifen
und kann sich in den kommenden drei
monaten nur mit bus und bahn fortbewegen
der adac warnt vor den folgen der
raserei leere straßen sind für manche
menschen auch in der einladung schneller
zu fahren aber wir waren ausdrücklich
davor weil schnell fahren ist immer noch
eine der unfallursachen nummer eins das
ist sehr gefährlich und gefährdet auch
andere menschen vor allem die
schwächeren verkehrsteilnehmer wie
kinder und radfahrer also unser
dringender appell an alle
verkehrsteilnehmer nutzen sie die freien
straßen nicht aus um ihre fahrzeuge
auszufahren
halten sie die geschwindigkeit regeln
ein denn wir als polizei werden diese
auch überwachen
geschwindigkeitsverstöße sind keine
kavaliersdelikte und verkehrsregeln
gelten auch in ausnahmesituationen wie
wir sie gerade erleben die schwächsten
in der gesellschaft trifft die krise
besonders schwer für viele obdachlose
sind öffentliche essensausgaben der
einzige weg um zu einer warmen mahlzeit
zu kommen aber auch hier wird die
versorgung immer schwerer
kurz vor 22 uhr in der hamburger
innenstadt sylvia sänger und die anderen
ehrenamtlichen helfer vom verein
zwischenstopp straße obdachlosenhilfe
packen für ihre runde
in zeiten von corona ist das mit vielen
auflagen verbunden ich habe heute mit
der polizei gesprochen wir abgesprochen
wie man es am besten macht dass wir
immer nur mit zwei leuten unterwegs sind
versetzt auf verschiedenen strassen
seiten damit wir keine leute in
anführungsstrichen anlocken und keine
versammlung oder keine menschenmassen
anziehen
zweimal in der woche waren sie bislang
hier mit essen kleidung und
hygieneartikeln eine zentrale
ausgabestelle aber geht nicht mehr
die standen alle noch da aber jens ist
vorgegangen und hat hauptsächlich die
leute dann
weg gemacht sage ich jetzt mal nach dem
bescheid gesagt wenn ihr hier irgendwo
hauptkarte seid hier kommen auf die
platte und nicht zentraler ort weil du
kannst nicht die christen nicht dazu
abstand zu halten und um das geht nicht
auch für die ehrenamtlichen helfer eine
schwierige situation
sie schützen sich so gut es geht rund
2000 obdachlose leben nach offiziellen
angaben auf hamburgs straßen
die dunkelziffer ist wohl doppelt so
hoch die hilfen der stadt nehmen viele
nicht an
so hauseingängen und das ist so kalt
ohne der stadt decken
das ist so kalt und von corona hat er
schon gehört auch deshalb möchte er
nicht in die notunterkünfte der stadt ja
ich will auf der straße das der beste
schutz oder sie gerade meinten wenn eine
ausgangssperre käme also wenn man nicht
mehr draußen sein darf was ist dann
betrüblich
zu hause können hier muss sich die stadt
irgendetwas einfallen lassen weil wo
sollen sie hin
es ist keine ahnung eine der drei
städtischen einrichtungen ist derzeit
wegen einer corona quarantäne
geschlossen was aus den obdachlosen wird
sollte es doch eine ausgangssperre geben
kann niemand sagen
solche maßnahmen sind hier in hamburg
gegenwärtig noch kein thema wir
beurteilen aber die gegenwärtige lage
jeden tag neu und nehmen entsprechende
dann nötige anpassungen im hilfesystem
vor das hilfesystem hier in hamburg ist
weiter so aufgestellt dass es
existenzielle und grund sicherungen für
auch obdachlose menschen bereithält dass
weitere einschränkungen wegen der korona
ausbreitung möglich sind ist bei vielen
obdachlosen noch nicht angekommen
er war ganz geschockte warum wir denn
handschuhe und mundschutz habe ich ihm
das erklärt dann habe ich gesagt
möchtest du desinfektionsmittel haben
und die die hände sauber zu machen hat
er gefragt ja warum denn die hände dann
habe ich gesagt ja weil mit den händen
und du das in den mund und nase kriegen
kann nur wenige obdachlose können sich
per smartphone informieren kontakt
untereinander haben die meisten nicht
aktuell den nachrichten verbreiten sich
also auf der straße sehr langsam
wir wissen auch ehrlich gesagt nicht wie
die leute sich verhalten werden wenn wir
alle nach hause gehen ist sehr schön
aber ich meine wo sollen die leute denn
die auf der straße sind also dass es uns
im moment nicht so wirklich klar leider
gottes erstmal planen die ehrenamtlichen
helfer für die kommenden sieben tage
essen und kleiderspenden jedenfalls papa
sie genug
professor hendrik strikt direktor des
instituts für virologie am
universitätsklinikum bonn ist uns
zugeschaltet und beantwortet jetzt
zuschauerfragen zum beispiel schreibt
dollar holbeck ich habe einen mundschutz
aus festem leinenstoff und trage
einmalhandschuhe schützt das ausreichend
gegen das virus
also wir hatten das in den letzten
wochen ja auch schon gehört dass der
einen mundschutz dem man sich selber zum
beispiel nehmen kann dass der sehr
effektiv ist andere menschen zu schützen
also wenn man einen husten hat oder
einen schnupfen dann ist es gar nicht
schlecht so einen mundschutz zu tragen
um dann auch ein bisschen solidarität
mit seinen mitmenschen zu haben und zu
zeigen wir wollen ich will das nicht
weitergeben
es hilft aber nur bedingt gegen eine
eigene infektion genauso handschuhe
haben den vorteil dass man sich weniger
ins gesicht und an die schleimhäute an
den bund an die nase fasst aber genauso
darüber ist eigentlich immer noch der
bessere weg
eine gute händehygiene zu haben also
regelmäßig hände waschen reicht
eigentlich vollkommen aus ok helmut
croteam himmel fragt ich habe gelesen
dass menschen je nach blutgruppe
unterschiedlich anfällig für das virus
sind stimmt das da gibt es in der tat
eine studie aus china die zumindest die
daten
sagen dass das menschen die eine
bestimmte gut blutgruppe haben dass sie
vielleicht ein wenig anfällig sind für
das virus
aber das ist jetzt erst mal auf solchen
sogenannten preprint servern gelandet
also da ist hat man noch keine gutachter
darauf geschaut und man sieht auch es
hat eine ganz kleine population in der
diese studie durchgeführt wurde
also ich bin dann noch ein bisschen
skeptisch wenn sich das bewahrheiten
sollte dann müsste das wirklich aber
auch erst mal einer großen studie
gezeigt werden als es noch nicht
verlässlich ellery anfragt wenn menschen
keinen sicherheitsabstand halten und ich
nicht ausreichen kann hilft es dann zum
schutz die luft anzuhalten ja auch dazu
gibt es eigentlich keine studien und
wenn man dann nur mal kurz an jemanden
vorbei geht da gibt es keine sorge dass
man sich infizieren müsste also wir
wissen mittlerweile dass eine infektion
dadurch zustande kommt dass man eben
länger mit jemandem gespräch und in
einer im näheren umgang war
wenn man kurz an jemanden vorbei geht
dann gibt es überhaupt keinen grund sich
sorgen zu machen muss man aber auch
nicht die luft anhalten
monika es fragt wie hoch ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit vor oder während
einer geburt infiziert zu werden
die wahrscheinlichkeit ist nicht größer
aber auch nicht geringer also aber das
gute ist dass schwangere und vor allem
auch ungeborene oder neugeborene kein
erhöhtes risiko haben schwer zu
erkranken ist man nach einer
überstandenen infektion eigentlich immun
ja davon gehen wir aus dass man
zumindest ein teil immunität hat also
für sechs monate zwölf monate vielleicht
sogar zwei jahre eine einen schutz hat
vor 12 aber wir wissen von anderen
bewohner wie
die ja auch heimisch bei uns immer in
den wintermonaten vorkommen als
grippaler infekt dass man sich doch
wieder nach zwei jahren ungefähr wieder
mit diesen viren infizieren kann
aber dann meistens die symptome nicht so
dumm sein andrea tyce fragt mein mann
reinigt eine stunde nach der schließung
einer arztpraxis muss er jetzt auf
besondere hygienemaßnahmen achten sie
das kurz beantworten könnten
nein gar nicht also gerade als
reinigungspersonal säubert man ja gut
und normale händehygiene reichte aus ok
danke an professor strick und sagt
corinna kompakt das finden sie täglich
auch im internet auf youtube und zwar
auf dem kanal der zdf heute außerdem
können sie uns weiter ihre fragen an
unsere experten schicken von denen wir
dann einige hier im studio beantworten
die e mail adresse dafür ist kroner
kompakt zdf.de und sie können sich die
zdf heute app auf ihr handy laden
da gibt es immer wieder auch live
spezialsendungen und interaktive
erklärende stories zu unseren themen